trying
uh unconfusing to a novice user and
macro is the word the manual uses when
it's
when it lapses into computer science
jargon
but they're the same
um
really in concept and probably uh
the new manual will just say that we
call them control sequences because they
control tech and they're called macros
because everybody programmed computer
knows what a macro is and
and uh
i don't know anyway that's the now on
the other hand for web uh we also have
macros and we don't call those control
sequences we just call those macros
um those are things that have been
defined
with uh with the with the define in
instruction in
your book
now to represent
a control sequence
in tech there's
that means backslash
something uh
is a control sequence and the something
is either well there's three kinds one
is where the something
is um
uh one character long
and uh another case is where the
something
consists of two or more letters
and this letter means that it's that the
chakod the the code the type of the kick
of the character
in the chicago table is eleven that's
that's what a letter means so those are
things that if you have two or more of
those that makes a control sequence in
tech like backslash end
then then there's uh the third kind
which is an active character and that's
when the chocolate is 13
and those are those are
um are uh
something like
single character control signal but
they're separate from the one from the
backslash
and so is backslash ampersand would be
different from ampersand if ampersand is
jakoda 13 in tech82 not in the old
version of tech but in the new one
it makes a difference to the scanner
also between those last two types the
control sequence starting with a
backslash
always ignores spaces
that follow it
so an optional space always follows uh
follows a control sequence starting with
a backslash but an active character
one of these
code 13 kind of things
does not gobble up any space after it
so the space after that will will
survive it
okay that
now in the uh
inside the machine we also have to take
care of
of
making sure that these control sequences
can disappear at the end of a group if
they've been defined inside of a group
and
we have to uh let's see
uh handle four kinds of control
sequences that can be defined
they can be defined to be long
or outer or both
now remember long it means that it's
their parameters can take
the end of a paragraph symbol
um
and an outer one
is something that's supposed to be
uh illegal to use except when you're at
a quiet time somehow somehow in an outer
part of the file not within something
else
both of these ideas long and outer are
intended to catch a common error of
someone mis
misplacing
a right missing a right brace somehow or
not matching up a parameter
because
of some type typographic error and
instead of scanning all the way to the
end of the file we want to catch it real
quick so if you if you run into
something that's outer
then you know you've made a mistake
so for example people will define
something to be outer
if
it's uh the beginning of a of a theorem
in a in a math paper
you shouldn't have a beginning of a
theorem in the middle of some formula
right
um
and uh
and uh
you define something to be long
if it's a if if you expect that the
parameter to that macro will
possibly have more than one paragraph in
it but otherwise as soon as somebody
gets to the end of a paragraph and
hasn't finished
uh the argument to a macro
uh if the macro isn't long then
tech will stop right there and and uh
and recover
uh with with some luck it'll recover and
go on to the next paragraph with a fresh
slate
so
so we just mark those
four kinds of control sequences long
outer or both or neither
question here please please reach behind
you for a microphone and push the red
button
no it has to go on the videotape
push the red button right button
do they have to be declared to be long
or since they're
equivalent to backslash colon something
they automatically see they don't take a
parameter so it doesn't matter it's only
affects whether the parameter contains
backslash par or not
now an empty line and backslash par are
supposedly exactly equivalent
they should even match each other as as
as parameters go
okay now we've when we've got a long
control sequence defined in there or
macro whatever you want to call it
we have to have have a way to represent
it inside it inside of tech and this is
the other
uh important data structure that appears
in mem these are all one-word items and
they're called token lists
and token lists are
defined somewhere other let's see the
table of contents
part 20 starts in module 270.
so um
token lists are explained
there with a bunch of definitions but
the real explanation starts on the next
page
well
you got to turn the page back and forth
on here
so what i wanted to do when i'm
representing a token list is have
something that in in a half a word i'll
be able to represent everything that
tech might want to be scanning
so i have 16 bits to work with
at least um
now what do i what do i actually get
when i scan uh the letter a
i get a command code
and a character code so if i scan a
letter a i get an 11
and a character code which is 65
for the internal code of a capital a
11 is letter
and this is uh okay it's a number you
know you don't have to know these
numbers you don't have to memorize them
or anything if you were tracing with
commands it would say the letter
a
because it would look at the that the
command code 11 and it would look at the
character code and figure out how to
output its internal character code 65
and 11 which would mean the letter
now the now um command codes are very
important and we'll talk about those
shortly um but within a token they
they're restricted they can only
actually be between 1 and 14.
um
none of the commands coming through in a
token list are going to be 0 nor will
they be greater than 14.
um for um and some of those aren't the
same as the codes that some of them are
i guess we might as well look at those
four first 14 codes the command codes is
that is a page
that defines all these internal numbers
it's uh module 201
as i'm writing the tech program i'm
actually referring to this page more
often than any other page
but i don't think the reader has to it's
just that as writing it i had to make
sure that i had all the commands in
there um
but
uh anyway they
think the uh
the the low the small command codes that
that's in module 201
they're all uh
they include the two codes and then we
double use the ones that could never
come through
so escape for example is zero because if
you give it your code of zero to a
character like a backslash it to make it
an escape
that's the code however
never will a backslash with something
with an escape code actually come
through into a token list because that
starts a control sequence and you're
going to go ahead and get the whole
control sequence
so that command code is also
used to mean relax and uh
our left braces on code one is only left
brace two two is right brace uh
and so on and then we get number five um
if somebody had a carriage return a a
character coded five that acts like an
end of a line
and uh again it will never come through
the scanner because we get to the end of
line you look to the next line to get
something and and put a blank through
the scanner
uh so five is also used to mean output a
macro parameter
and
it's also used to mean backslash cr so
it's got three three purposes here
and for a character it'll never come
through
if you type a hash mark that could come
through as a six and so
so on with all these other ones we get
to an active character a 13 it's going
to be again a control sequence so it's
going to be replaced by something else
it won't come through the scanner as a
token
but the end of a paragraph is going to
come through as a as a 13 and so will um
something let's see match your macro
parameter no that will be interrupted by
actually matching the parameter so end
of paragraph
uh i guess can come in as a 13.
no
what happened no actually
let me see um
yeah no no this 13 would come through
but it's only because it's stored inside
a token list itself
so this these 13 and 14 are special
special uh commands that that are
inserted in
uh
into token lists just so that we can
do our funny things with parameters when
we're when we're fetching them out of
the scanner um and they never come
through for user characters anyway this
this command code will always be some
number between 1 and 14 and none of the
other values are possible there this
chair code could be anything from
1 to 127 0 to 127
for a character
and
that's one case
of a token the other case of a token is
a control sequence
like backslash relax is the simplest
control sequence but there are other
uh you can use can you see this far down
no you can't see it
um
yeah
good idea
okay so um
if
now to get backslash relax coming
through the token we wouldn't give the
command code for relax
but instead we'd give
the um
the hash table pointer for relax
since this since uh
between the time you define uh uh
something with relax in it and the time
you use it you might have changed the
meaning of relax or this might be some
control sequence that wasn't even
defined yet so for this we want to point
to
the table
of um equivalence for each identifier
there's a hash table that uh a table
that'll associate with every every uh
sequence of letters that you've used uh
somewhere relaxed will appear in there
and that will tell what the meaning of
relax is and there will be a there will
be a command code
and a sure code associated with relax
at any given time
but in the token list we'll just have a
pointer to this word we won't have the
contents of this word since this might
might change
so now uh when we represent then uh
a definition of the list of tokens each
token is either
a pair of command and char like this or
it's a control sequence no question uh
tony
toby
the
the characters and the fonts are
extended 256 but these tokens are still
limited to 127.
um
the in a font you can have 256
characters but on your keyboard input
uh
7-bit codes are are only accepted so
so somebody does not
so we are not
accepting
256 codes in the extra array
the extra
array um
and the xord array
um
extra gives a
gives a uh let's suppose for example
that we were on a cray where they have i
think nine bit uh
nine bit uh characters
or say absolute where you have eight bit
characters okay let's say absolutely so
in that case um
x cheer
of um 65
would be some eight bit character
xord would be an array that takes any
8-bit character into a 7-bit internal
code but my internal codes are only
7-bit for for the things in the buffer
for example in the string string pool
are all 7-bit
so you have 128
internal codes that tech would work with
um that's not a terribly inherent
restriction except that the
if you wanted to work with larger you'd
have to increase the size of the chacod
the uc code lc code dell code sf code
table
because all of those are indexed by 0 to
127
but you you would have room for
well no i don't add min quarter word to
this to this guy either i don't think
so you would have to well anyway there
would be room though because i
i actually compute the value of this
token by taking 11
multiply by 256 and add 65.
i compute the value of this token
by taking a large number sufficiently
large like 2 to the
10th or something
oh two to the sixteen two to the twelfth
i guess
um because this will never be more than
fourteen so it certainly won't be
sixteen that would be two to the
fourth times two to the eighth would be
to the twelfth so if i say two to the
twelfth plus uh the location
of of relax in the table will represent
a control sequence
uh so if so uh we call this two to the
twelfth is called the cs token flag and
if you add cs token flag to the location
of the c of the control sequence then
you've represented the control sequence
as a token
um if you have anything less than two to
the twelfth anything less than this
token flag then you divide by 256 and
you figure out what the com the command
and the character parts are of it
as far as the
but as far as extending the the
type ascii code to eight bits
uh this would
lead to incompatibilities with other
versions of tech
yet i don't think it would mess up any
other data structures particularly
one character uh web
says that one character constants
um are used for string 0 to 127
and
that would also that would also have to
be changed to allow
one character classes to be larger
because webb's internal code is
identical to text
when you say
double quote a
in double quote in a web program it's
supposed to give the text the same
internal code that tech uses
the internal code is of course just
internal so
you you know it's it's an arbitrary
mapping if we can handle ebcdic we can
handle anything
but uh
but as long as it only maps in the
longest only gives us 128 different
possibilities
on end then we can move those 128 into a
spot into uh 256 or 512 afterwards but
we just won't won't fill the the the
whole range
now the um
so the data representation of tokens as
i said
has two cases because there's two kinds
of tokens there's the control sequence
tokens this includes all three kinds of
control sequences
because all three of them are located in
the same
array
or the kind that are packed with a
command and a character together
now
in order to
demonstrate see
in order to demonstrate that again
there's a procedure called show token
list and that starts in module 273
and it's just two pages long but it goes
through and interprets a token and a
whole token list and that's what prints
out a lot of the things that you would
see in in tech uh
when you have a when it's storing when
it's showing you uh what hit what it
thinks a macro was
uh it's using this show token this
procedure now there's some more
complications though that i gotta
mention
because of parameters you see a token
this can has to also represent the fact
that a macro might have parameters that
we want to match
and so that's all explained in module
272.
um and and there's a
an example there which i might as well
put on the blackboard but it's also in
your it's also it's also in the note now
the example
um
is a definition of a macro and we're
just going to show how that how that's
represented inside step by step so you
get the idea so somebody has typed into
tech define
backslash mac
a
one
dash two
space
and then um backslash b
and then a space space of course will be
ignored uh since it follows a control
sequence
then left
brace
hash one
backslash minus a
space
hash
one
this is not intended to be the simple
example this is intended to be the one
that shows you everything
or so that it so that
you'll be completely puzzled at first
but if you have a little patience you'll
feel like that
that that nothing once you figure this
one out then you'll feel that you have
total power to do all there's
now this is the so this example
is uh
shows
all the kinds of things that can happen
except for a uh
matching a left brace uh which is a
slightly special case now um okay mac is
going to be a token list inside the
inside of tech
and
we
and it's going to be
in that one word area of memory
uh linked together and this left the
info parts of each word
is going to be a representation of the
token
uh so let's see what they what it would
look like well first of all
um you would have
a letter
and hey that's type of 11 but let's
write it symbolically so letter a that's
your first that's the first one
then you have uh a parameter number one
now you don't store that as hash mark
one
uh well for one thing the one is
redundant because the first parameter
has to be number one
so instead it just says
match
a parameter and doesn't give any number
in it at all
but it does give
the
uh internal code number of the hash mark
because somebody might
have several different
uh
symbols that he that he's using
for for macro parameters whatever type
that is six or something um and
whichever one he used uh we could
reflect there and type it out
in that uh
as that character if we are asked to
type out this token list so we save that
character there we call it match but
then the one is suppressed um if the
person wrote two here give him an error
message saying uh uh you know illegal
you're supposed to number your
parameters consecutively or something
like that and then uh
that would catch uh catch an error of
where something else probably was wrong
up above
now matching
um
so so these two go into just match
and duplicating the the character code
internal code of this guy
similarly for that one
and then a blank space
a blank space is type spacer in the
command code
and
the code
for space
i could mention that all
uh um that all space codes no matter
what the character is if it's a type
spacer i convert it to a blank
um on input so that they'll all match
each other when you're studying when
you're matching macro parameters a
carriage return a tab
um
anything that you've said is of type
space will match in a macro
and the reason is
that
this had caused many errors where people
were trying to they would make a
definition and they would in one place
have a carriage return another place
have a space or a tab or something and
it would look okay on their screen and
say what's going wrong
um so everything
everything that's been defined to be a
type spacer is actually converted you
tech doesn't remember anymore what what
what this spacer was if it was an
asterisk and somebody said asterisk was
uh to code 10 it would just be
equivalent to a space
um
then comes letter
no
that's ridiculous that's a that's a bug
um
okay
well that's a that's a bug in the
comment there
uh
so this would be a control sequence
b so this would be um
uh yeah this would be control sequence
so this would be cs flag
plus
the location of b
um
is the next thing
and uh
so i guess
like in other words um i can represent
that notationally as just backslash b so
cross off the word letter there that's a
mis that's a misprint in that line you
should just say backslash b the control
sequence for b
is the next thing after this blank space
and then
no blank space for that
then comes a special token called end
match
and end match is the um
is the command code at the uh and the
chair is zero i believe so the end match
is a command code of 14
and
matches a command called 13
i guess
and uh yeah and and this tells tech that
uh when you when you're trying to look
for mac um then you get here you
finished now you've got all your
parameters
now
uh proceeding then we would go into the
first thing and this would say out param
one this would say it's time
as we're continuing to read this token
list to now start reading parameter one
that we've already found as we've been
reading this part of the token list
and then it would say
i'll do this control sequence and i
would say letter a
and it would say blank space
then it would say what well
now in a right hand side of a definition
two hash marks in a row is used to stand
for a hash mark so this would now say
mac row parameter
hash mark
and then this is a
other char one
it's not a letter it's in digits aren't
specially noted so this is a one of type
12.
um this is parameter two so it's out out
param
two
a
blank space significant
after a digit usually not significant
because the digit's usually a constant
but in case of parameters
uh parameters are only one digit long
this space is there blank space
and um again out param2
and then the link of this last token
will be zero or will be null i mean
indicating that the token list is over
with okay so inside of the inside of
tech there would be this list of half
word numbers
and it and you asked the show token this
procedure to print these
and it would
print what well
what it prints is shown on an example of
the next page and 273
um it reprints the letter a
then it prints
uh hash mark one
now it knows what your character is it
knows what your hash mark character is
by looking here it learns it as it goes
because you might have used some other
symbol and tech isn't initialized to
think that this character is any
different than any than any others
um uh and different token lists might
have different hash characters in them
um
and then
hash two comes out blank space comes out
and control sequence b now whenever a
control sequence
ends with a letter
this short token list automatically puts
a space after it
just in case the thing after it is going
to be a letter it doesn't look ahead to
see if a letter is next if a letter were
next it would be a bad mistake to leave
a space out so there's always a space
after
um uh of this if it's a letter um i
think maybe even if it's not a letter i
forget now in the old tech it would it
uh it made it made a decision but i
think now it always puts a space out but
i don't remember for sure
um
and then it gets to end match and it
translates that into a
hyphen and a greater than sign
to
to look something like a
right arrow
then comes
out param1 gets translated into hash one
okay
um
presumably you're not using out param
unless you've already had parameters so
it's already learned what what code to
use for that parameter
however yeah okay i think it it can
learn always in time so it puts this out
and it says there there's no space after
it so i have to double check the code
and see if it if it does that or not
it says backslash
backslash hyphen without a space and i'm
not sure about that
i'll double check it then letter a
space
macro parameter that comes out as two of
those symbols
one comes out as a one and so on to the
end
now let me see how does that so let's
see if we can figure out from this code
what comes out when i'm displaying a
control sequence
so the
the token list procedure
looks like this i'm reading from
from module 273
it's got several
parameters the p is the main one that's
where the token list starts
q is another one that's only used uh
with if we're printing out error
messages if we get to position q
we're supposed to do something to switch
from line one to line two of the error
message and l is an upper bound if we
get to printing out too much output
we'll quit no but no sense going any
further than uh than that upper bound
okay now uh
come into the program and it's it
sets matcher to the hash mark just in
case we haven't learned it in time i i
think that's only to make this procedure
robust uh in case of a token list that
wouldn't really have
have arisen in the course of
of a tech job
n is zero that's the number of
parameters we've seen so far and tally
is the number of characters we've
generated okay now it so
the main thing we have to do is display
token p and return if there are problems
so that's module 274 let's look at 274.
if it's p is out of range then we print
escape clobbered
with a period after it
so we're debugging and you're printing
out a token list and you get to a
pointer that it's not in the one one
word area of memory
um then
something is definitely wrong and we
we're going to give up we're going to
print clobbered with a period after it
or we can tell that distinct from the uh
control sequence clobbered
because why
because if the if if the user had a real
control sequence clobbered
uh it would also have it would be get a
space after it instead of a period
so this way at least we'll be able to
look at the message and see that it was
a that was
this kind of error indication but this
procedure is not supposed to ever call
error because it's used by the error
routine to describe the location of an
error
okay now if info p is greater than or
equal to cs token flag then we're in
this case where we have a control
sequence that we call on our subroutine
called print cs which prints a control
sequence otherwise we're going to divide
by octal 400 or same as saying 256 and
break it into the m and c part the m is
the
command code and the c is the character
code
we print bad
with a period after it
if we happen to have a negative token
for some reason
or
or a character code greater than 127
otherwise we are going to display it in
the uh fashion it's got the next page
okay so we gotta in order to solve our
problem as to whether a space comes
after this or not we have to look up
print cs
where in the heck is print cs well for
that i gotta look in the index
now sometimes i thought it would be neat
to have
a subscript on all my identifiers saying
where they were
defined so i could save one
one step in my search excuse me
245
okay thank you
trouble with that is that some
identifiers are declared many times and
so i wouldn't i would have to know about
the scope of each one and it would be
quite tricky
now that
okay print cs uh it says it prints the
name of a control sequence and a space
after the name if it in consistent type
of letters
and so um uh that's the idea here then
it will not get up space after this
backslash hyphen
unless hyphen had been checked to be a
type letter
uh another and it goes through the three
the three cases of a
of a of a control sequence
now um
here we get i want to talk about another
one of text big tables this is the table
uh called the the table of equivalence
and the
table of equivalence is
where we keep
all of the meanings of the of all the
control sequences
the table of equivalence is uh described
starting on
pa on module 213
and it's called
eqtb
it's one of the few places where i've
used a cryptic abbreviation instead of a
word
in the in the uh or something
unpronounceable as an identifier in this
program
i used to do that a lot and now uh
having the
the freedom to use multi-letter
identifiers it turned out usually better
to have a long pronounceable identifier
but this darn one was used so often i
couldn't see myself
writing out equivalence table and i
couldn't think of a good uh
in between so it's called eqtb and i
don't know what i say to myself
except it or something like that when i
read it i'm sorry about it but anyway
there's six parts to eqtb
and um
they aren't equal size but um
uh i'll
i'll just uh
pretend they are for the time being so
there's six regions
and um let's take a look at what they
are now the first region
is uh
one character
control sequences
so these are the uh the things that we
there's 128
of them that could be active characters
type 13 characters and then there's 128
of them that is backslash character
backslash a backslash hyphen and so on
so so um 256 all together
one character control sequences
the next region
is the greater than or equal to letter
control sequences
uh the third region
is for
skip
some glues
blue parameters
fourth region
is um
uh what i called uh well half word
entries but it's it's like local
quantities but it's half word entry uh
things like the name of the current font
uh the name of the current par shape
um
and uh
and all of the boxes like box one the
box zero up to box 255 pointers to those
boxes a pointer is a half word so this
will this will uh
boxes are now local
um they'll go away at the end of a group
unless you define them to be global when
you said set box
and so
anyway it's put into eqtb
then these are integers
here
and the last are the dimensions
so it has six
parts to it
uh and it's used for keeping local
quantities everything that i want to be
subject to the
local mechanism the thing of going away
at the end of the group is stored in
eqtb
now
especially the control sequences
um
something now for the for these entries
um
in in regions one to four this funny has
six regions and they're slightly
different in their feature but one thing
they have in common
is that they are uh are going away at
the end of the group
now in the first four regions for each
guy in here we start a command and a and
a modifier called the chur to the thing
the command is a quarter word
and sure is a half word
so every um
every control sequence for example has a
command that indicates whether it's a
ordinary call or a long one or an outer
one or long and outer
or it might be a tech primitive so it
might have a command code that says this
is a
a def instruction or something like that
so the command code says what this
control sequence means
um
the sure code is a half word so it might
for example in the case of a control of
a defined control sequence by the user
h would be a pointer to the mem location
for the beginning of the token list
well it's not really the beginning of
the token list because there's a
reference count first
we for each token list we keep by
account of how many times people are
using the token list whenever that count
drops to zero we flush it
and uh
this is uh
it has turned out to be quite a quite an
efficient way to do things so um
uh
the it's a pointer to the reference kind
of a token list in the case of a call
instruction but it's a half word the
chur field is a half word and you have
these for all four parts that's what the
equivalent is
this is called the command field is
actually called the eq
type and
this part is called the equiv
and then later on if tech is using it
through the scanner eq type gets called
the command and equip gets called the
cher
some of the eq types are special that
should never come through the scanner
for example the
current paragraph shape
is stored somewhere in in this region
here
and its eq type says par shape
and uh some uh but par shape is when it
comes through the scanner it's not
supposed to be in the current paragraph
shape it's supposed to mean the command
to set the paragraph shapes a different
thing entirely
so
par shape here means to take
this equivalent has to be
recycled in a funny way when you're when
you're coming to the end of a group and
and you're going to give up this par
shape and go back to the outer one you
have to return a par shape node to the
free memory
um and that's why you look at the eq
type to see that so some of the some of
the eq types are command codes that
would come through the scanner some of
them aren't but in in any case all of
these guys have a type indicating what
the equi what kind of equivalent it has
now here um in the last two regions
though they don't have a quarter word
and a half word associated with them
they have a full word an integer
or a scaled value of course because an
integer
wouldn't fit in a quarter word and a
half word
so in those regions when we fetch a word
out of region 5 of of eqtb we expect to
take a whole integer out of it
now region two is special because it has
a hash table associated with it all of
these guys furthermore have a hash array
that runs from the beginning of region
two to the end of region two the hash
array
um uh will give information as to what's
the name what are these uh what are the
letters in this thing
so they have pointers here um
and one of them is a pointer to the
string table
of it's the number of a string so we can
say where what the name where the name
starts in the string pool the other one
is a pointer within the hash table to
other things that uh belong to the same
list uh uh that uh we
we take the letter sequence and convert
it to a small number
and then we everything that get that uh
has the same
uh value of that number would would get
linked together
or the method actually used for hashing
is a
is called the method of coalescing lists
and uh
with a um
with the refinement that uh uh my
student jeff vitter
wrote a thesis about so that it's we
actually
choose this hash value that we can we
take every sequence and we we convert it
to a so-called hash code which is a
which uh is a number somewhere about the
first 85 percent of this table
and um
and the first things that don't
that that uh when we have two things
going into the same place the first ones
go into the last 15 percent and start
filling up the table until finally the
overflows come into the main table
itself and jeff's thesis show that 85 is
the right number to get the best
efficiency out of this method you can
expect that these lists on the average
are going to be of length something like
1.7 or some some small number so that
very rarely you actually have a long
number of things to check
uh there were details about hashing that
are
in in another book i wrote so
so um uh anyway that's a hash method but
the hash table then an array called hash
starts at location at the beginning of
region two here and ends at the end of
region two it's only used for that part
of the table
now these equivalents then um
where we keep um control sequences so
let's recapitulate what i said
suppose somebody says def
uh a
um you know and then he puts b here okay
fairly simple case so what's going to
happen
tech is going to to look to to see this
backslash here it says oh escape
character um it's going to be a control
sequence and it looks at the d e f and
then it sees a non-letter and so it says
okay d e f is the thing i'm supposed to
look for it's a control sequence
uh made up of more than one letter
so it computes a hash code for def
say the hash code is 300 it looks at
position 300
and
points to a string and says does that
string number three uh
string indicated by this is that def
uh whoops no it isn't one def okay look
at the at the at the link here on and
we'll look at another place in the hash
table that points us to another string
ah yes that is the ef okay what so we
found the ef at this part of the of the
eqtb what does it mean so we look up eq
type of def that says that's define
that means you're defining a control
sequence
and so
you found def that it means defined
okay the define routine
looks at the next token without
expanding it as a macro
and
and uh what happens it sees an escape
sequence it sees a letter
so it says oh maybe there's going to be
another letter we'll have another
control sequence of more than one letter
no it's not a letter it's a
code one it's a left brace kind of a
token so this is a one letter control
sequence
special case of one character control
sequence so we look up here we don't go
through hashing on this one we pick it
up out of eqtb and we look up here
what's its eq type
but we okay but we're going to define it
so what no matter what its eq type was
if it could have been def also it could
have said define whatever its eq type
was we're going to change it and make a
new definition of it we're going to put
in this place an eqtb
call which is the command code the eq
type for a
an ordinary defined control sequence
and then we're going to
run a little program that's called scan
talks that that reads the left brace
goes to the end
build a token list for this thing puts
it in a big memory array and then the
equiv is going to point to that um to
that token list
and we'll have a call in here
now but what about what used to be in
there before i put the car on there a
was defined to something else
i've got to do something with that
because it's got to come back again
later on when i get to the end of the
group
okay
so um
that's that's the uh last link in our
chain here
um
and there's another
uh table
of importance
called the save stack
this is where we save things
that have to be restored later
so the save stack
is is full of memory words
that are going to
be put back on the
on eqtb later let's suppo let's see now
backslash a
is in location uh
well um if you work it out it's a
hundred and twenty nine plus six plus uh
97 whatever well whatever let's say
might as well get it right
226 i think in location 226 there's
going to be uh
backslash a
and so it's going to be represented as
location 226 in eq tv
now when i'm redefining that there was a
previous meaning to backslash a i don't
care what it was uh
let's call it
star because it uh
just whatever its previous meaning was
when i define it again
this previous meaning is going to be
wiped out except that if i'm inside of a
group at the end of the group previous
meeting is supposed to come back
so what i'll do is in the save stack
maybe the save stack already has some
stuff in it
here i'm going to put the old thing that
used to be
for a
and then on the next word under it i'll
put
226
indication that 226 has to be fixed up
when i get to the end of the group
okay
so the save stack contains a lot of
two-word items like this
and the 226 also has a type code
associated with it saying
fix up 226 okay something like that
now
usually
when i'm doing this
this control sequence didn't have any
meaning on um it was just an undefined
control sequence outside in the outer
block
and so i'm wasting space on the safe
stack so there's a special case it says
easy fix up or whatever it's called uh
in the case that this star star was the
uh was the the most common one of
undefined control sequence and easy fix
up it only saw one word and and assume
that that that the previous one was he
depicted but that's a technicality it's
conceptually it's the same idea it's
just a small refinement to it to save
space so what we put in that when we
change something on the eq table
we put an entry on the save stack and
this would be the address in eqtb
and if the address is one of these high
numbers we know that
we're that the thing where we're have to
restore is going to be an integer or a
scale or a skip or a half word or
something by by the range of this
address we can tell what um uh what kind
of a fix up we're going to be doing if
it's a small number we have to look at
the eq type to see what kind of a fix up
we're doing but if it's a large number
we know it's an integer yeah
uh please use the mic
how do you know how much to restore um
if you have nested the braces
down to several levels so that yeah you
don't want to restore everything yeah
good question see uh we have to we have
to uh store more information you pointed
out that that my data structure is
incomplete but fortunately there's room
for another quarter word here
because i had a half word in the quarter
word white you know yeah yes i have
another thing called eq level which is
the level at which a thing was defined
and this is important because if i
didn't have that i wouldn't be able to
do it right
so so now besides this i have a level
and this is the level at which the
definition was made
and then this number is a little tricky
you have to work it out in fact
uh in the first version of tech
i think about
six bugs were in that section because i
kept learning more and more about this
scheme as i as each time i thought i
finally understood it completely
now i think i do but
i'm not sure i can explain it to you in
five minutes
but there is a level at which at which
the definition is made
and so level goes in with it and if this
level turned out to be the same as the
current level
then i don't even bother putting
anything on the save stack
because the previous definition because
something already was saved from an
outer level so suppose for example i'm
on level three inside of three pairs of
braces
and um and i have two depths of a
when i did the first f of a
then i saved something for fixing up
later i did the second f of a i just
throw away the first f i don't have to
star away at first f
if i started away it would take up space
and i would undo it and then i would
undo
undo that again so you know so
no point in wasting the space and doing
extra work so i just throw it away at
the time if it's the same level
but if it's about but if it's at a
different level actually i must be at a
higher level because it'll because it it
is going to be a property of this whole
method that every level on the save
stack is less than or equal to my
current level i think strictly less than
my current level
i'll never save anything and and when i
restore the save stack i'm gonna when i
get to the end of a group i'm gonna pop
back until i get to the right place in
the save stack so besides fix up words
in the safe stack i might have another
fix up word here
and then i'll have a a boundary type of
a word here
okay a boundary type of a word that says
this is the this is where i began a new
group
there will be a boundary word up here
too
beginning of a new group okay
so when i get to the to a right brace at
the end of a group
i i run back and i do all the fix ups
until i get back to the preceding
boundary
and now everything is restored to the
way it was when i entered that group
you get the general idea of this of this
method um
so the last input so when i get to the
beginning of a when i get to the start
of a group suppose somebody writes hbox
and then left praise okay i'm beginning
a group
so everything in in here when i get to
the right brace it's going to tell me um
uh
you know then i'm going to uh
go back and restore all the definitions
things that were made in this group and
that'll be indicate on this boundary
here
now i need a few more pieces in my data
structure and you're probably going to
discover this yes no
okay
now the way the old version of tech this
is a a big change between the old
version of taking the new one and why
the new one can be a lot better
um
the old way was that i kept in this
boundary word here uh what kind of a
group was starting there for example in
this hbox case this would say beginning
of an h box
but i didn't remember that what kind of
a group i was
i was in
instead i would go through do all my fix
ups until i got back to bonding with
this
and it would say oh that was an hbox
group that you were doing so i was a
right brace came along but but at this
point i had forgotten
uh really what kind of a thing i was
working on
and uh but i but i knew it was somewhere
in the same stack and so i just went
back to it and then and then it told me
uh yes it was uh it was an hbox group
and so then i go and finish the hbox
um
now for the for tech82 this would this
would be very bad because if we wanted
to get rid of hbox power and things so
if this was a v box and if i would
destroy all this stuff here i'd be about
to make a paragraph but i just erased
the baseline skip that i was supposed to
use for that paragraph
so i uh so i want to know when i have
this right brace that i'm in a v box and
still have to finish that before i do
the before i like i go doing these fix
ups
so the uh
so the new data structure
um stores store i have a i keep track of
what kind of group i'm in it's called
cur group the kind of group i'm in
and then in the boundary word i don't
store the the kind of group that was
starting there but the kind of group i
interrupted so this boundary word is
going to be a pointer to the previous
boundary word and it tells what kind of
boundary word that was
therefore when i get to the end of a
boundary
when i get to a right brace i look at
kerr group and says oh yes i was
finishing this such i'm finishing such
and such a kind of group
and if i want to i can do these fix ups
as soon as i and at the right time i can
do the fix and i finally do the fix ups
then i then i said curve group to the
old curve group that was that was stored
there and and resume as i as i had it so
the same saving and restoring
equivalence gets a bit subtle
and it's all described
in
let's see part
19 of the program starting at module
251.
so though so the the the problem of
saving and restoring equivalence in that
part of the data structure
is discussed there and it's one of the
most subtle parts of tech the program is
actually short
it covers modules 251
up to um
up to 269 um
so it's it's it's a
rather small amount of code but the code
itself uh
had to be just right
in order to do all these features uh i
haven't described what what about global
definitions yet and that's the that's
the other uh interesting thing about
this which you add on top of everything
else i said what happens when you said
global or g def of a
and in that case
you
you don't bother saving the old value
because you're never going to want to
put it back again
and
you set the eq level
to one
and uh if you look carefully at what
this does and you have to consider all
the cases where you have uh
say 10 definitions and some of them were
local and some were global and see
exactly what gets stored and what didn't
uh you'll see that it does in fact work
um
so so uh that's the the other catch is
that when something is global and i try
to fix it up i'm coming through in the
right brace and i try to fix up
something and i look and see that the
thing that's in there is that level one
that means it was defined global in the
block so i don't really fix it up at all
and the yeah
yep
dan
is there any other use for eq level
besides that
oh no well it's important for uh garbage
collection um because if i didn't know
that then i wouldn't throw away things
at the wrong time uh
at the right time there i would lose my
last reference to a token list
so um
so that's why i have added an extra
quarter word array
called xeq level here
to regions five and six
so that i can have the level information
for these two guys which didn't have an
extra quarter word
so regions five and six is extra arrays
of one by each for these guys saying
what their level is without that um
things would go wrong at one point i
thought i could get by with it but then
i found out later that i couldn't so it
uh so i needed all of the if i needed
all the structure of levels and boundary
and uh and so on it's all it's all
wrapped up and if any one of those
things goes the whole thing falls in
some cases even though it would it might
work for a few months
this is the way uh no this this kind of
thing
can
can
actually work on all the simple examples
and then and then it'll fail on the
other so now i believe it's been thought
through uh with perfect rigor but it's
it's a it it was one of the subtle parts
of the of the program uh worth worth
studying i think for
for uh software people
um okay that's the uh then
representation of control sequences and
uh equivalence
and uh the subtle parts about it were
related really to the garbage collection
issues that i just hinted at um namely
there's a reference count on each token
list so suppose i've saved uh something
on the stack it's a
suppose i've saved
this and this was a pointer to some
place in memory
the old definition of a
all right so um
uh that token list has a reference count
associated with it
now
um i i did a depth of a well then later
on in this block i did a g def of a
um so at that point i wipe out this
definition i set the level to one
but later on but this fix up is still
there in safe stack i'm not going to go
back looking through the safe stack to
see if i had any fix ups for the thing
so then when i finally get to the right
place and i come through i see fix up
226 i look and see oh the level's been
won so there's been a g def to this guy
i'm not going to fix it up i have to
remember to decrease this this reference
count
on this entry that i'm not going to use
i don't just ignore this one i i i
decrease its reference count that was
one of the latter bugs to that i caught
that
i had been losing
losing my memory at one point because of
this
um
yes i'm forgetting all these things uh
losing space in my mind
um
okay um oh i wanted to make a
point about this a little bit that at
level one at the outermost level you
don't have to save anything
because there's never going to be a
right brace getting you out of that
level
and so you so so um you you um save
yourself
it that's why people have had the
phenomenon that the tech will work fine
on a program then they put left brace
and right brace at the around everything
and all of a sudden it runs out because
save stack overflowed
um the reason is that when you when
you're in level two
when you're you know when you're inside
of braces then i'm starting to having to
save everything and in the old tech it's
saved every time you change the font
every time you change current font it
puts something on the save stack
and pretty soon if you had a long enough
program the save stack would have lots
of fix up font fix up fonts in there
well now it not only i think i don't
think it will will change the font
anymore because i have level on the font
i didn't used to
uh but i have um
uh but but uh it still will will use
memory more efficiently if you don't
have unnecessary
unnecessary uh braces uh here okay now
some
other questions
uh yes
if if you have a definition in the outer
level then
i can't hear you sorry sorry if you had
a definition in the other level say a
backslash a
then it would have uh level one
and then
yeah um
uh
levels level one is what inside the
program when it's level one is the
technical term used for
the outer level
because level zero
is the is the uh
is is completely undefined
and and so we considered an undefined
control sequence was defined at level
zero
um that's a technical point when i send
an error message to a user i say he's at
level zero when he's when i think he's
at what i call level one because he's
has he's not really inside of any of any
braces
so for example at suppose you write this
this tech program left brace end
when i see the left brace
i set ker level that's one of my
parameters one of my global variables is
ker level
when i see a left brace
um ker level goes up from level one to
level two
and i see end and i check is ker level
greater than level one and i say oh yes
it's at lev it's level two this looks
strange
so i tell the user end occurred at level
one
it doesn't use the word level though
it's i change it fix the error message
so it's a little more
uh makes a little more sense uh
but
it um
it it says one instead of two even
though my my date my uh
the number in inside of tech is two i
reported to the user as one if you if
you want to understand what i'm talking
about it's all much clearer if you look
it up in the code
and end occurred that's
module 1203
when you're just finishing tech
uh one of the last things it does is it
gives this message um
and it said and it end occurred inside a
group at level
and then it prints out ker level minus
level one
if you can think of a more
informative error message than that that
seemed to be one that my wife understood
it's my test
excuse me then
you have it yeah uh
does it work yeah um
what what happens if on the outer level
you get i have a slash def you have a
def slash a
uh second level you redefine it and the
third level you g definitely okay yeah
let's look at this case just to see what
happened
so he then here i said g that big okay
yeah so
on the outer level i defined a
nothing goes in the safe stack because
its previous definition
was i mean i'm still at level one so
nothing is in the safe stack here
there's no way to take this one away
um
it'll never end at a group so i never
put anything on the safe stack for that
here i put something on the save stack
and so
um
this will be then uh two what was it 200
and whatever
two what
226 okay i'll say fix up 226
um let's call this um
okay alpha beta and gamma okay
so at so after i do this definition i
stick alpha in here when i get to this
definition
it'll say fix up 226 alpha
and beta gets stuck stuck in here
when i get to this definition
oh and also this will say level two okay
and this will say one alpha
okay
now i get to this definition uh this
definition i'm at level three
um
and so it it's not equal to this level
so i put it on the save stack
2 beta picks up 226
and put in here three gap well one gamma
g def one gap
okay get to the end of this group
what
uh why do you put on the sales taxes it
was a g def
you're right
i didn't put this on
so there was a g def didn't yeah that's
right yeah i didn't put it on i just
wiped it out decreased the reference
count to beta
then
okay then when i when i get to the right
brace here
i
i look back and i see it's going to uh
no nothing happens i get to the next
right brace that finishes this group and
that will tell me to fix up
uh this definition here but i look in
position 226 and it's got a global in it
and so that's uh so it doesn't get fixed
up
now on the other hand if somebody had
made a def of a at this point
then it would have some something at
level two and i would and i would go
back
and uh and that would have wiped out the
g def
at this point you see
so it's the last survive the last g
death survives but uh but it can be
death can always be con
canceled by a local dev
and this one would this one would store
away this guy
gamma
and then that gamma would be restored
and when i finally got in and so finally
when i got to this one it would still
not
it would still not replace gamma by
alpha
it's that's what i meant by saying try
it and you'll see that it works and
there's a and besides there's a uh
an informal rendering of the uh proper
invariant relation that that gives uh
the basis for the mathematical proof
that it works stated in that section
there what was it 250 something or other
um
i i believe somewhere i
i
i at least hinted at what was the right
notion of it um
let's see
new save level
well i can't find it just now
uh well
yeah 265. if at least one global
definition of eqtb has been carried out
within the group that just ended the
last such definition will therefore
survive
and that um if you translate that into
quantifiers and logic and everything
would be the the right thing to put in
as in a formal proof of correctness of
this algorithm
there's a there's another complication
that i didn't mention of course with
respect to if and and
so when you say if
then the level number doesn't actually
go up
when when you pass this left phrase
and so when you get to the right brace
afterwards
um you just take out the boundary word
and shift everything down
uh you have to read the code but you'll
see that it works
okay any more questions
well uh tomorrow morning then uh we we
begin the class at 9 30 and we begin
breakfast
at uh about nine o'clock so come early
enough and have some have some uh feed
oh um
start at the beginning i would say and
again and
start at the beginning read some of
these comments and familiarize yourself
with use of the index and then set
yourself some problem or other in other
words something say i wonder how he does
that
now the way you can do that that's a
good question uh
if you take any any one of text
primitives
like def or something like that you can
look it up in the index under that name
and it'll say def primitive it'll refer
you to
the place where it was put in the hash
table and then that will refer you to
what command code it has and you might
be able to trace through looking at the
index the whole seek the whole history
of of of deaf how it comes through tech
but this anyway give yourself if you
don't like that problem give yourself
some other little task so you know
saying i wonder what this hap
what this doesn't and and that'll just
give you uh um
a a reason for perusing the index and
and and finding your way through the
report because the main thing to do is
just to get a little familiar with the
notation and
and
mess up the page the the get the pages a
little a little black on the edges